so good morning everyone how's it going
all right so me and shreya are going to
be talking to you about BQ plot today
it's plotting library and in Python but
before I start we we have two versions
of this doc that we give one that's you
know much flash here and one that's more
introductory so just for a show of hands
how many people here have heard of BQ
plot or seen a demo okay all right fair
enough
I will go through the introductory
version then okay so what is BQ plot so
the way we describe it usually is that
BQ plot is an interactive plotting
library for the jupiter notebook that
means a lot of things that I'm going to
explain soon enough but it's an open
source library that we developed while
we were at Bloomberg at Apache license
and on github and usually when I say
this people say I'll got another
plotting library I have like eight
different api's to do memorize at this
point I haven't done a single line
charts and without Google since 2009 so
yeah that's that that's that's fair but
in some sense I think it represents the
diversity of the Python ecosystem that
we have different tools for different
use cases so the question is then why
learn BQ plot or why Google how to do
things and be key plot is it the way I
say it and the way we usually describe
it and non PDF is with moving gifts that
say that with 19 lines of plotting code
you can usually do the entire
demonstration Hahn of Hans Rosling's
famous Walton Nations and with eight
lines of plotting code you can generate
nate silver's you know famous election
map and all of this code is in Python
and a full fledged web web application
so so yeah so the the reason that your B
key plot can be more interactive than
other libraries is because it's really
built for the notebook and the notebook
is built in a web browser so we can
really leverage d3.js and all of the
incredible work that's been done on the
JavaScript side for data visualization
and the best part is we can
find that to Python functions what that
means is that your Python code can now
serve like a JavaScript I kind of like
in in the same way as JavaScript
modifying your visualization on the fly
and on top of that we're built on top of
the iPad which is ecosystem and that
means that any other library that's
built on top of it whether it's you know
I by volume the 3d live plotting library
passage is the mapping library library I
PI leaflet they all play extremely well
with us um so the B cube law team is
mostly at Bloomberg I'm at Amazon and
Silva is at Kuan stack in Paris we're on
github and as a like any other open
source project we always welcome new
contributors so ok let's let's go to the
demo okay so so B teapot has do
different api's one is a very matplotlib
skb huh fullscreen and but the Mac when
you fullscreen nichrome does funny
things yeah I am I usually avoid that
but I can zoom in yeah so it's too much
yeah so beaky plot has a mad lib ask API
and the reason I say that is because we
try to emulate matplotlib as best as we
can in some senses we you know we avoid
it if we think that the API in MATLAB
was cumbersome but so it just like
matplotlib you can do PLT scatter with
your X data and your Y data and you get
a nice little scatter plot the
difference in BQ plot and and in
fairness to mateluna I think the newest
versions have are similarly built is
that this is an entire interactive web
application so it has panning zooming
everything that you would like just
directly when you plot when you generate
a plot you can save the plot refresh do
whatever you like the big thing about BQ
plot is that it is really an interactive
library so when you declare the scatter
every trade of every trade every
attribute every part of it is an
interactive widget
that means even after you've generated
the scatter you can go back and change
it so if I do scattered out why and I
change the data you see it's the
original plot that's going to change and
I can do that n number of times and I
don't have to redraw anything actually I
can add animations and that's going to
give me something a bit funkier so it's
going to show me how the data is moving
there I can change the colors I can
change the shape of the scatter plot but
the most powerful thing for us comes if
you have an arbitrary function let's say
foo and we want to we want it to do
something
whenever someone interacts with the plot
we can define foo and we can say for the
scatter observe foo whenever the y value
is changed let's let the user moves the
scatter values so if we go back here we
date this point and we move it that's
going to call our function directly
there was no Java Script involved in
this all of the JavaScript has been
taken care of Carrick yeah it's been
it's been done by us rather yeah and not
that I want to recall it but uh if you
if you see it also passes all of this
data to you tells you what was changed
the old values and the new values so you
can use that to really customize what
kind of reaction you have any time the
user interacts with your plot in a
specific way how do we use that so we
try to do a lot of things with it we we
generate funky little maps sometimes
other times we I mean basically for us
so in eight lines ten lines of Python
code this is a County map depicting the
winners for each year and you can you
can make the tooltip depict any aspect
of the data that you pass to your map so
in this case I do the color so you can
see at each point you can zoom in you
can say inspect the counties and all of
this is done in Python taking the data
creating a tooltip and then creating
just doing PLT Ruggiero which creates a
plot so the so that's that's kind of how
we use it we we give ourselves kind of
free interactivity the cool thing is the
tooltips can be any sort of widget so if
I define another figure let's say the
world map I can put I can put a tooltip
in it that shows a line chart so you
could have the GDP for each country if
you like when you hover on it that's a
pretty good exercise that we usually
leave to the audience is that change the
line chart on on depending on which
country you're hovering over we also
have the notion of selections so you can
click on a point and select it and
that's going to change the selected
attribute of plot usually you don't see
anything so the best way is to change
the style for the selected and
unselected points and you can go and
select multiple ones if you'd like and
you can then let the user and you can
define a custom reaction based on which
ones the user has selected this works
for countries line charts bars it's kind
of a uniform API so one thing I didn't
mention was that be key plot interacts
really well with the rest of the widget
framework so how do you use that so
imagine if you had something like linear
regression you you know you you fit you
fit a line through the squares it's a
bit like dropping a line vertically from
that on to this really under from each
blue point under the red line but you
want to see how your outliers are
outliers affect particularly the the
slope of this model let's say what you
could do is you could take this point
and move it and on each move you could
refit the regression line and see how
the regression line changes because of a
single outlier and as you can see it's
kind of badly affected by it it's a one
more problem with linear regression so
you could try different curve methods
that correct for this regularization etc
what you'd see is that yeah so it's it
kind of gives you a convenient way to
have all of your numerical code which is
already in Python mix with interactive
visualization without really without
having to write any JavaScript or
anything like that another cool example
that we always have is that polynomial
regression so this instead of fitting a
line we can fit a second-order
polynomial or a third order and
gradually as we increase we see we start
overfitting and we start having weird
behaviors so that's that's always a fun
visualization yeah so another cool one
that and okay so all right I I'm gonna
give it to you eleven sigh I go quicker
through the thing okay so one one one
cool visualization that we have is
related to the M Ness data set and it's
kind of the baby steps of deep learning
you you have handwritten digits and you
and you classify them so imagine if you
were working with this data set the
first thing you like to do is to look at
your data so you can go through and look
at all the different plots you see that
these you see you know some are pretty
pretty funky and distorted and I think
that's how the data set was generated
you can also use a projection algorithm
like geese need to take this very high
dimensional image it lives on at 784
dimensions or something like that and
project it down onto your onto two
dimensions so what that means is that
you can have a nice little scatter plot
which shows you where all the points
line you can try to identify patterns
within those points the issue with that
is that actually what happens is the you
I mean you see distinct clusters but
it's pretty hard to see what this
anomaly is without going and looking
back so one thing you could do is you
could put the actual picture as a
tooltip and go and see which things are
not very really mixing well and you can
you kind of get an intuition that some
of the why some of them would not mix
well the other thing you could do is you
could say okay but now I want to kind of
separate them out so that I can actually
classify them one of the famous ways of
doing that are convolutional neural
networks so here what we do is we take a
pretty simple Linette like architecture
and we look at the last dense layer
so the last the last layer before we
classify anything and we look at the
representation that it's learned and if
that representation is in clean probably
your model is not going to do very well
so what we can do is we can take the
output of this intermediate layer
perform a DC on it and then see what
kind of representation the second last
layer of the carnet is learned and as
you can see it's kind of very separable
much cleaner much nice you could imagine
why this this would in particular work
really well and I think its accuracy was
something like 98% on the validation set
so so it does work really well but you
see some of the points are kind of
strangely classified so say this one so
you can you can go there and say okay
let's what happened there the actual was
one and we predicted three so let's read
this data point to the network and let's
see if it adjusts its parameters in
order to learn it and you see yep it
within a single epoch it did that so now
hopefully you've got it right yep and
you can so you can go and inspect your
data and essentially see where exactly
you're going wrong and it's a bit manual
but in if you're really facing problems
with a certain class it can be helpful
and then you can regenerate your TCE
plot and what in general you see is that
you still see some points but that point
that you just trained will probably move
back within its little cluster the other
thing you could do if you want to
interpret it is look at the kernels for
the first layer see these little Gabor
like things and you can really inspect
them the BQ plot allows these kind of
nice layouts just like MATLAB and yeah
that kind of that helps us understand
where exactly we should be fixing our
nets how exactly we should be tweaking
our architectures it's one way we use
interactivity to kind of modify our
workflows trees are going to show you
show you some other visualizations that
are actually a lot
once I'm going to leave him do that so I
can see them do thanks Ruth so I'll have
like 15 15 more minutes so I'll try to
go over these relatively fast so yeah
like carrying on with the neural net and
deep learning deep learning tools and
visualizations that we have so here we
are looking at the data set which is for
predicting the defaults of individual
customers so yeah so this is like the
very famous skagle data set it is called
give me some credit and so what we have
here is we have some so first we are
trying to monitor how the training and
test accuracy of our model evolves over
time so on the x-axis we have the epoch
and on the y-axis we have there you see
the metric that we are looking at and
yeah so here we can interactively see
how the training test error is evolving
and depending on how much of a gap we
see between the train and the test we
can add more regularization to our model
or add more capacity and so we can
interactively proceed based on what we
see and so but this is like a very
aggregate level analysis we ideally want
to get more deeper into the network and
try to understand exactly what is going
on so sorry this is just taking a little
bit of time it should be done should be
done pretty soon I have 15 new box so in
in the meanwhile while this is getting
done I will just go over to a different
example so this is the very famous
Wealth of Nations example which many of
you would have seen so it was done by
Hans Rosling in which your we are
representing the GDP per capita and the
life expectancy of the different
countries so I will just quickly show
you what we have and yeah so I'll zoom
out
okay so what we have here is on the
y-axis we have the life expectancy and
on the x-axis we have the income per
capita and each bubble here represents a
country with the size being proportional
to the population so this is a very
famous visualization which many of you
have seen so we can go through the data
like as time evolves by like linking it
with the I PI widgets slider so if we do
see that yeah on the whole we are
getting better in the sense that we
would ideally want all the countries to
go to the top right corner and so but to
understood an animation so here we use
the I PI widgets play button so yes so
it's very easy like entirely in Python
you can add this animation where you can
see how each country is moving over time
and and then you can take that you can
like use the slider and so to add a
little bit more to the traditional
visualization we added a tooltip so you
can hover over any country and see the
entire path that it has traced over time
so we do see for many of the countries
that there is like this dip near World
War 1 and World War 2 where the life
expectancy especially dropped quite a
bit but yeah so this allows you to like
understand your data a lot more easily
and try to analyze it very easily so
yeah now that this guy is done so yeah
like we do see that going back to the
neural network example we do see that we
are increasing the training error the
training accuracy is increasing but the
test is slightly decreasing so maybe
maybe overfitting a bit but to
understand what the network is doing we
have a representation of the graph and
we can see different attributes of the
network by just hovering on so what we
are seeing here is the tooltip for for
the different nodes so
screw and so here you can also see that
on the right we have the incoming nodes
colored according to the the color of
the bar chart so we can see if all of
the layers are being used or if it is
like super sensitive to one a few of the
layers and you can also have because all
of these can be computed using blue one
here and most of the other neural
network training packages that we have
so here we can also look at the
gradients and we can see how the
gradients are evolving over time and we
can get a much better understanding of
what the neural network is actually
learning and then we can try to
understand like how to tune it and
analyze it better so next what do we
have so since I work at Bloomberg we had
a financial data company I have two so
this is like a pretty good financial
example that we have so all of you have
heard that in crises like all of the
market becomes a lot more correlated
than it usually is but so you can like
test this by looking at the correlation
correlation matrix in crisis situations
so here what we have on the left is the
price series of the Dow Jones and on the
right we have the 30 stocks correlation
matrix so now we want to see how it
changes over time
so in BQ plot we add what is called a
select and so here so this selector
actually selects a sub subset of the
time period and by going down we narrow
by moving up and down we change the
width of the interval and then by moving
across we can we can change the time
period so we can focus on a crisis
situation and see how it actually
affects and we do see that when there is
like a huge market drop in like mid 2015
the market all of the stocks do become a
lot more correlated and so as I don't
remember who exactly said this but there
is this saying that the point of data is
to get inside and
BQ plot what we try to do is to provide
you tools and ability to build
visualizations which allow you to gather
insight very quickly from your data and
I have a couple of more things to show
so yeah this as you know like most of
the mobile companies have like huge
patent infringement and lawsuits going
on so this is a representation in
Thomson Reuters website of like which
mobile companies suing whom so you can
see that pretty much you can see that
pretty much everybody is suing everybody
else but what do you see here is it's it
I think this visualization is not very
clear you get a global picture but then
there are like too many lines and you
don't really understand what is going on
like at a very big picture so then Mike
Bostock has this visualization which he
did using the d3 force layout so here
you can see so if you want to look at
say just Google you can see that they're
just being sued by Oracle but then Apple
is is like in the middle of this whole
big thing so next we try to create a we
create this using BQ plot using just so
here this is just an import and this is
like the dictionary of all the data that
we have and using the graph mark we can
recreate this but then yeah we have to
add more interactivity so that you can
easily understand your data so now if
you hover on Apple you see that only the
term only the links which are connected
to Apple are highlighted and then you
can easily understand for each company
what is going on rather than looking at
this which is like slightly horrible and
so next oh yeah it's so next we have an
example in neuroscience so this is what
is called magneto encephalography so
what it tries to so in the human brain
when you see something there are
electrical spikes or signals in respond
to the stimuli that you see and the mag
this M eg for short this tries to
measure the magnetic field generated by
those electric spikes and then tries to
understand which part of the brain is
responding to different stimuli so here
we take this unsuspecting guy put this
inverted r2d2 on him and using that we
get so we we can measure like what is
the response generated by different
stimuli in different parts of his brain
so what we have here is essentially a
helmet which is recording the response
of different parts of the brain and so
this is a 2d projection of the helmet
seen from above so the front part is the
nose of the person and this is the left
of his left of his head and this is the
right of his head so the colour
represents the spatial location of the
different different electrodes now we
try to see like how the brain responds
to different stimuli and what parts of
the brain are activated so this is the
entire recordings of the M eg over just
finded milliseconds so which we do see
that there are like two big spikes where
there was some response to stimuli but
like for the rest of the time it is like
pretty flat so the colour corresponds to
the area from area of the brain from
which the stimuli came so now so we can
try to go to the two spikes and try to
understand like which part of the brain
is being activated in each of them so we
see that for the first spike like most
of the activation is coming from the
right side of the brain and the left
side left side and the right side of the
brain and also from the back but not
much from the front and we can also
identify what is happening with the
right spike so we can also see that for
the second for the second spike that we
have the activation is kind of similar
it's more or less like the sides of the
brain which are mainly activated and
then the mostly the back but as drew
said we can easily link this with most
of the other eye by Richard based
frameworks so now we have sorry
yeah sorry I'm really bad with the
macker don't use him back yeah no that's
how big you made it actually yeah that's
that's kind of happy you mean you can
rerun it and see if he gives you better
size man yeah thanks
so yeah you can now this is like a 3d
representation of the helmet so you and
and then you can see like on different
times what is the different parts of the
brain which is activated so that you can
get like a good understanding of like
you can easily understand your data you
can see where the signal is coming from
and then try to ask the right questions
and quickly do your analysis so yeah
that is sorry that is pretty much all
that we have for now we have like five
minutes
so yeah if you have any questions
[Applause]
can you explain like what technology is
like BQ plot is based off of and also
like how it performs like with with
larger data framework so on the Python
and the JavaScript side and for the
plotting we are mainly using d3.js so
we've written like our own abstractions
on d3.js so that it represents the kind
of top-level classes that we want to
expose and for performance so like if
you have a lot of data since this is
like we render most of the marks in SVG
we do slee see some slight performance
hits but then you can like always
overcome that with basically using some
kind of data decimation algorithms so
that you like intelligently subsample
your data and then only plot that and
then we can have like interactive
zooming and then once you zoom in to a
part then we can render that dead bad
data in greater detail and typically
when you have large amounts of data you
don't really see anything so we try to
have simple things that you can do to
just have a quick visual of it and then
you know kind of dive deep into it and
have interactivity for specific subsets
of it time for one more question
with the new jupiter labs supporting the
vega light spec how does that relate to
BK plot in terms of visualization
bloodwork's in jupiter lab with the
latest version of 0.20 7.1 and yeah so
like it's almost the same as how you
would write and render as in the normal
Jupiter notebook and yeah on top of that
because you were pasted on the widgets
we can have apart from the custom
extensions we can have different other
types of extensions like we can mirror
outputs so you could create full scale
canned visualizations that are being
controlled by Python notebook
and that are being displayed separately
so in the case of the training monitor
you could be looking at your code
inspecting your data in a notebook but
you can mirror the output in a separate
davon Jupiter law and then monitor the
you know their training and lost history
curves you can monitor the gradients you
can do things like that in general
we've seen that's pretty hard to take a
lie I mean it's not that easy they're
not we really built for a scientific
computation I'd say because we're
scientists who built this for ourselves
so we yeah using it we we see that the
things that we wanted to support in
Jupiter laughs tend to make it easier to
do scientific things I thank you very
much everybody we have another session